today's new member of the day's James
feel James thank you so much for being a
david pakman show member support
independent media sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership and let's
take some phone calls our phone number
is six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty six one seven eight three
zero 47 50 is the number we'll take our
first caller who's on the line today all
right Larry we could barely hear you so
we're gonna just get you turned up a
little bit here as much as we can just
so I can hear Larry's question Larry
from North Carolina okay go ahead what's
on your mind industrial hemp have you
ever noticed how all the talk is about
marijuana hmm and at the same time
industrial it's far more lucrative than
marijuana and I was wondering if you
ever noticed why no one ever talks about
it I honestly have no idea I know very
little about industrial hemp and it's
something I'm willing to learn about it
I'm certainly open to that but I don't
really know anything about industrial
hemp does anybody here do you know about
industrial hemp at our founding
documents the Constitution and
Declaration of Independence were written
on hemp and George Washington and Thomas
Jefferson we're the top hem farmers of
their day is that really true well ok
you know it's far you know industrial
hemp it's so far advanced you know and
so much money can be made with
industrial hemp there and you smoke and
it won't get you high okay man I just
know nothing about the hemp world all
right Larry thank you so much we will
take it under advisement and see about
the future of industrial hemp I really
appreciate the call Larry thank you so
so much
Gamefly is sort of like netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 PS
for ps3 Wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can play as many games
as you want for one monthly fee and if
you find some games you want to keep you
can buy them for a low used price
there's never any due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a free 30 day
trial at Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included there's
no contracts and you can rent games
through the mobile app get the free
30-day trial for the David Pakman show
audience and support our show by going
to Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s